how many alien civilizations are out
there
in those four phases that you're talking
about when you look up the stars
and you're sipping on some wine
and
um talking to other people with british
accents about something intelligent
intellectual i'm sure
uh
do you think there's uh a lot of alien
civilizations looking back at us
i'm wondering the same my
romantic view of the universe is really
i'm taking loans from my logical self so
what i'm saying is i have no doubt i
have no idea
but
having said that
there is no reason to
suppose that life is as hard as we first
thought it was
and so if we just take earth as a marker
and if i think that life is a much more
general phenomena than just our biology
then i think the the universe is full of
life
and the firm the reason for the fermi
paradox is not that
um
they're not out there it's just that we
can't interact with the other life forms
because they're so different
and i'm not saying that they're
necessarily like hasn't depicted in a
rival or other you know
i'm just saying that
perhaps
there are very few universal facts in
the universe
and that and maybe um
there's not it's quite the technologies
are quite divergent
and so i think that it's very hard to
know how we're going to interact with
alien life you think there's a lot of
kinds of life that's possible i guess
that was the intuition yeah
you provided that uh
the way
biology itself but even this particular
kind of biology that we have on earth
uh is
is something that is just one sample of
on nearly infinite number of other
possible
complex
autonomous self-replicating type of
things that could be possible and so
we're almost
unable to see the alternative
versions of us
huh i mean um
we'll still be able to detect them we'll
still be able to interact with them
we'll still be able to
like which uh what's exactly is lost in
translation why can't we why can't we
see them why can't we talk to them
because i too
have a sense
you put it way more poetically but
it seems both statistically
and uh
sort of romantically
it feels like the universe should be
teeming with life like super intelligent
life
and and uh
i just i sit there and the fermi paradox
is very
it's felt very distinctly by me when i
look up at the stars because it's like
it it's uh the same way i feel when i'm
driving through new jersey and listening
to bruce springsteen and feel quite sad
uh it's like louis c.k talks about
pulling you off to the side of the road
and just weeping a little bit i'm almost
like
wondering like hey why why aren't you
talking to us you know it feels lonely
it feels lonely because it feels like
they're out there
i think that there are a number of
answers to that i think the firming
paradox is is perhaps based on the
the assumption that there's
if life did emerge in the universe it
would be similar to our life
and there's only one solution
and i think that what we've got to start
to do is go out and look for selection
detection
rather than an evolution detection
rather than life detection
and i and i think that once we start to
do that we might start to see really
interesting things
um and we haven't been doing this for
very long um
and we are living in an expanding
universe and that makes the problem a
little bit harder
everybody's always leaving um but i'm
i'm distance wise i'm very optimistic
that we will
well i don't know there are two movies
that came out in the same within six
months of one another at astra
and cosmos at they're very expensive
blockbuster you know with brad pitt in
it and um saying there is no life and
it's all you know we've got a life on
earth as more pressures and cosmos which
is a uk production which basically
aliens came and visited earth one day
and they were discovered in the uk
right it was quite it's a it's a fun
film
um and but i really loved those two
films and i'm i i and at the same time
those films at the time those films are
coming out i was working on a paper
um
a life detection paper and i f it was so
hard to publish this paper
and it was almost as depressed i got so
depressed trying to get this science out
there that i felt the depression
of the the film and al astra like life
is there's no no life elsewhere in the
universe and but i but i'm incredibly
optimistic that i think we will find
life in the universe firm evidence of
life
and it will have to start on earth
making life on earth and surprising as
we have to surprise ourselves and make
non-biological life on earth and then
people say well you you made this life
on earth therefore it's you're part of
the causal chain of that and that might
be true but if i can show
how i i'm able to do it with uh very
little cheating or very little
information inputs just creating like a
a model planet some description and
watching it watching life emerge then i
think that we will be even to to
persuade even the hardest critic that
that is it's possible now with regards
to the fermi paradox
i think that we might crush that with
the jwst
it's basically if i recall correctly the
mirror is about 10 times the size of the
hubble
that we're going to be able to do
spectroscopy look at colors of
exoplanets i think
not brilliantly but we'll be able to
start to classify them
and we'll start to get a real
feel for what's going on in the universe
on these exoplanets because it's only in
the last few decades i think maybe even
last decade that we even
um
came to recognize that exoplanets even
are common
and i think that that gives us a lot of
optimism that life is going to be out
there but i think we have to start
framing
um
we have to start preparing the fact that
biology is only one solution
i can tell you with confidence that
biology on earth does not exist anywhere
else in the universe we are absolutely
unique
you